♪ ♪ ♪
- Le Vieux-Montréal recommence
à vibrer, mais à un rythme
assez détendu.
Ce jeune homme est venu avec des
amis pour profiter de la liberté
qu'offre Montréal. Il réside
à Toronto, où les mesures
sanitaires demeurent
plus strictes.
- Maintenant, avec les règles
là-bas, c'est pas très amusant.
- Cet homme vit avec sa famille
à London, en Ontario.
"Nous avions dû revoir
nos plans pour visiter Montréal
en raison de la COVID et de
la fermeture de la frontière",
explique cet homme.
"Je dirais que 70 %
des voitures que je vois dans
le coin viennent de l'Ontario",
ajoute cet autre.
Ça fait le bonheur de
ce spa de jour, qui accueille de
nombreux clients en provenance
de la province voisine.
- C'est comme jour et nuit.
- Les activités touristiques
reprennent.
D'où viennent les gens qui
sont avec vous aujourd'hui?
- Vancouver, Toronto, Montréal.
- Mais ce guide travaille
beaucoup moins qu'avant.
BRUNO LAJEUNESSE,
guide touristique
- Écoutez, un guide normalement,
dans une saison touristique,
fait deux-trois tours par jour,
sept jours semaine pendant
toute la saion,. Là, on en fait
deux-trois par semaine.
- Et l'affluence n'est pas
encore assez importante pour
ce copropriétaire de camion-
restaurant. Pour une deuxième
année de suite, il survit grâce
aux aides gouvernementales,
parce que plusieurs événements
sont encore une fois annulés
cet été.
FRANCIS ROSCONI, copropriétaire,
Smokiesfoodtruck
- Il y avait des grands
rassemblements pour enfants
qu'on n'a pas cette année,
le cirque aussi qui n'est pas
là, les feux d'artifice aussi
qui amenaient beaucoup de monde.
- Pour l'aider, il espère
que des événements extérieurs
seront organisés bientôt
dans le secteur.
- Nous autres, on marche avec
beaucoup de volume pour pouvoir
vendre un petit peu.
- Par ailleurs, un couvre-feu
demeure toujours en vigueur
de minuit à 6 heures sur
les terrains du Vieux-Port
de Montréal.
Et bien que les visiteurs ici
sont moins nombreux,
leurs sourires sont pour
le moins... contagieux!
Ici Olivier Lefebvre,
Radio-Canada, M